[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we're coming to you live
riverside from kyoto japan we really
didn't make it back to our live camera
location yesterday we had quite a
journey well show it to you throughout
the hour
shortly of course we'll be interviewing
the president right here in Japan who's
here for the g20 but back in our native
land the United States of America the
Democratic Party went completely insane
yesterday that's been happening for a
while of course insanity is a process
but last night at the first Democratic
primary debate of the 2020 season they
made it official elite Democrats have
permanently broken with reality they no
longer care about what's true what's
possible even what's real they live in a
kind of dream state a place of fantasy
punctuated by howls of
self-righteousness watches hooli and
Castro and keep in mind he was an actual
cabinet secretary in the Obama
administration it was only a couple of
years ago
watch as Lillian Castro explains that
men who get pregnant have a moral right
to taxpayer-funded abortions not choking
watch this I don't believe only in
reproductive freedom I believe in
reproductive justice what that means is
that just because a woman or let's also
not forget someone in the trans
community a trans female this poor
doesn't mean they shouldn't have the
right to exercise that right to choose
and so they cheered behold late empire
liberalism in full flower
who exactly is the constituency for
Castro's idea men dressed as women who
get pregnant that's the constituency
unfortunately there are precisely zero
people on planet earth who fit that
description not a single person actually
there never have been any people like
that there never will be any people like
that why because it's impossible
biological men cannot get pregnant
pretending otherwise is lunacy it's the
very definition of lunacy but a million
Castro doesn't care
taxpayer-funded transgender abortion
sounds like something that all good
progressives should support so Kat
strove fervently does and critically he
knows that nobody in the room will
defend science or paused to ask him what
the hell are you talking about
they can't say a word they're too
intimidated they know HR is watching so
they nod like monkeys as if everything
he's saying is completely sane oh good
point mr. secretary trans females
shouldn't have to pay for their own
abortions that's racist the whole thing
was like a cartoon or an evil and Juan
Avila non like this all night here for
example is Julian Castro agreeing with
Elizabeth Warren that it shouldn't be
illegal for foreigners to break our laws
watch when somebody comes across the
border not to criminalize desperation
[Applause]
criminalize desperation and you thought
this was your country just because like
your ancestors you were born here just
because you pay half your income to the
government to keep the whole thing going
you thought it was your country think
again racist America belongs to the rest
of the world your job is to shut up and
pay for it complain and we'll punish you
bill de blasio often makes that point
under Blasio the single worst mayor in
the 400 year history of New York City
that's impressive but how did he wind up
on a presidential debate stage last
night God knows maybe he illegally
immigrated there doesn't matter he was
there and once he had to Mike de Blasio
promised to seize your money and give it
to his supporters who he explained
deserve it
much more than you do yes we're supposed
to be for 70 percent tax rate on the
wealthy you hear folks say there's not
enough money what I say them every
single time is there's plenty of money
in this world there's plenty of money
this country it's just in the wrong
hands got it we've got the power soon
we'll have all the guns and more coming
for your stuff that was the major theme
of last night in case anyone missed it
the two widest candidates on stage
decided to repeat the point in stilted
Spanish cada vote are caca de votante
necesitamos la representación y cada vez
necesitamos escuchar yes
de presidente attack Tavo de mon asado
los immigrant is inacceptable a voy a
cambiar dress got that gringo
you can add the english-language to the
long and growing list of things the
Democratic Party considers racist how
long before you're banned from speaking
it think we're joking right
better to learn espanol if you want to
talk to your grandkids it's a brand new
world some of the least impressive
people in America are making the rules
hope you're excited for it at least men
will be able to get free abortions even
when they weren't speaking Spanish when
Democrats argued it was typically an
effort to one-up one another on
immigration who could be most radical
watch this I want to make sure I'm still
talking about everybody else you're
looking at just one small part of this
I'm talking about a comprehensive
rewrite of our immigration laws billions
of folks a lot of folks that are coming
are not seeking asylum wound up Fox's
Edie Henry was in Miami last night for
the debate and he joins us this evening
we're always glad to have him good to
see yet how was it
Tucker good to see amazing round two
coming up you laid it out pretty
interestingly one of the juiciest parts
of this story though is that not too
long ago hooli and Castro himself said
the border crisis was BS that's what he
told CNN now he's trying to break out of
the pack by beating up on the president
so he's saying just the opposite it's
such a crisis he said we need to do
something radical the word you used a
moment ago so radical the Democrat Amy
Klobuchar said timeout she said she'll
look at decriminalizing illegal
crossings but said wait the real focus
should be on going after human
traffickers who are hurting women and
children and people who are quote
unquote violating the law which remember
the president has said not for weeks but
he's been saying for years funny because
other big Democrats on stage tonight for
part two have also flipped Kamala Harris
said dealing with illegal immigration
was a quote distraction from the real
issues Bernie Sanders said there was no
crisis not a good look when
apprehensions at the border are up 623
percent from 2017 then there's bill de
blasio you mentioned a moment ago
pushing that seven deeper
cent tax rate for the rich he and
Elizabeth Warren went further they
raised their hands in favor of ending
private health insurance altogether for
millions of people Democrat John Delaney
who was on the stage last night told me
after he thinks that's political suicide
for his party one of the many reasons
why the real winner from these two
debates second one starting soon may be
the president United States dr. ed Henry
Thank You Minister you know what labor
unions think who's you know spent a
hundred years negotiating private health
insurance what they're gonna say about
that
well NBC brought five separate
moderators to last night's debate almost
all of them pure toady's to the
Democratic Party and together they spent
not surprisingly most of the night
tossing softball questions to the
candidates or questions intended to drag
out the Russian collusion hysteria
here's a selection we saw that image
today that broke our hearts and they had
names if you were president today oh
yeah what would you specifically do do
you have a plan to deal with Mitch
McConnell if the house chooses not to
impeach as president would you do
anything to address the potential crimes
that were outlined in mr. Muller's
report no US president has ever been
prosecuted for crimes after leaving
office do you believe that President
Trump could or should be the first its
from bad he's bad lots of softballs and
yet still no matter how easy the
questions most people seem to agree that
former congressman Bhutto O'Rourke
but clowned himself after the debate one
obviously smitten MSNBC anchor fussed
that he wasn't being taken seriously
Bhutto watch I do still think it's
interesting that there is just a snark
to the way you're treated whether it's
by the media or by the other Democrats
on stage and I wonder what your that's
what it looked like to me as someone
rooting for you're rooting for everybody
I think a big field helps all of us it's
certainly more fun to cover but you were
singled out you were targeted you were
attacked and I wonder what that was like
so you're a blushing fangirl okay should
you admit that in public on live TV
probably not but no matter how impressed
she was by bateau O'Rourke he's still
more impressed by himself watch this
but what grade would you give yourself
for last night
I'd give myself an A